il y a quelques mois notre précieux
ministre de la Santé qui soit pour voir
que quelques hôpitaux en France qui
galèrent nous avons expliqué qu'il
fallait se faire vacciner tous les trois
mois quand on était fragiles puis tous
les 6 mois c'est 10 et texte c'est 10
comme ça il a écrit alors là tout à coup
on parle d'un rapport annuel avec ça
c'est François brun qui a dit ça hein
François Brune qui a dit ça ouais c'est
Brown qui a dit ça c'est bon en disant
effectivement il fallait se faire
accepter trois fois quand on était
fragile tous les 6 quand on était pas et
d'un seul coup on passe à un rappel
annuel bon ok on a compris depuis
longtemps que tout ça c'était pas de la
science on a compris depuis longtemps
qu'il fallait faire un truc donc on le
fait on fait n'importe quoi ça va pas
s'arrêter maintenant on a compris il y a
pas commencé
[Rires]
quand tu as vu que le ministre de la
Santé a dit ça tu dis quoi c'est bon
c'est bon quoi c'est c'est ce que je me
suis dit je me suis dit en fait vraiment
ce poste est tellement sensible il est
tellement pourri le poste de la santé
que tu mets le premier imbécile venu et
ça marche
tu as vu l'état des services
hospitaliers tu as vu où on enlève moi
je l'adore tu sais que le nouveau
ministre c'est pas du tout
on peut ne pas être d'accord sur des
choses c'est pour ça qu'on sait bien
qu'on soit drôle je trouve très
compétentie il fait le travail il est
17h il fait des trucs il fait quoi il
bosse je te dis bosse je l'ai vu je l'ai
vu à la bibliothèque encore la semaine
dernière
alors oui toi tu dis oui bien sûr mais
quel est le problème il faut que ce soit
tu vas faire combien de vaccins par an
alors un parent c'est ça
par an obligatoire contre le covid pour
éviter que les hôpitaux et les services
d'urgence soit surchargés voilà je
préconise ça et je suis entièrement en
phase avec cette possibilité qui n'est
pas encore un ordre mais si c'est un
ordre monsieur division je suis
légaliste contrairement à vous je
l'appliquerai sans scrutin moi je ne
suis pas légal lui je suis naturaliste
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait pour moi
pardonnez-moi mais je suis formé la
culture d'Antigone et absolument pas la
culture de Robespierre
bah écoutez moi je sais pas quoi vous
dire bah moi rien c'est pas moi qui vais
boire et voilà en fait moi la campagne a
été un succès absolu quoi
quand effectivement il y a plus de
passion d'hiver qui avait plus de
contraintes c'est fini hein la quatrième
dose la poubelle personne n'en veut de
4e dose vous peut-être vous êtes un seul
alors les Français quand on les
contraint pas à travers un pass et quand
effectivement on porte pas atteinte à
leur liberté individuelle tout à coup
l'esprit de santé tout ce que vous
voulez la protection des fragiles ça
intéresse plus et curieusement attendez
curieusement il y a pas eu de rappel
vaccinal majeur pour 4e dose et il y a
pas eu de saturation extravagante donc
des Hospitaliers des hôpitaux même
Martin Blachier même Martin BL
ici était un fervent défenseur de
vaccination et du confinement tout ce
que vous voulez et tu as dit sur cnews
que bon les pays qui ont pas majorité en
vaccinés qui n'ont pas majoritairement
confinés qui ont pas apporté le masque
et ben finalement sur son lit alors bon
ça va repartir
c'est bon
la Floride qui vous a donné la parole
peut-être un Américain qui est passé
non mais en fait on sera jamais d'accord
et on sera jamais
la durée de vous poser une question
dure l'immunité combien de temps vous
irez bien mais moi je suis pas médecin
problème
d'ailleurs combien de temps dure
l'immunité moi j'écoute mon médecin
pourquoi on est passé alors moi j'écoute
mon maître le vôtre ou celui de l'État
j'écoute le mien celui de l'État qui
alors il a dit il y a trois mois que
c'était trois mois pour les fragiles 6
mois pour les autres moi comment on
passe de 6 mois 1 an je me trompe mettre
division mais je ne me considère pas
comme une personne de plus de 60 ans
encore puisque j'en ai que 51 et donc je
considère pas comme une personne fragile
et donc d'accord donc des fragile dans
ton petit cœur donc dans ce cadre là
dans ce contexte là
les deux si on veut faire simple les
doses de rappel c'est tous les 6 mois
a-t-il assuré le ministre de la Santé
admet qui explique en particulier si
vous êtes plus à risque vous avez une
maladie on va raccourcir ce délai à
trois mois
et là on parle d'un rappel
3 mois et 6 mois aussi mais moi j'étais
pas pour ma grand-mère si elle est très
fragile et très malade et très vieille
là parce que le problème c'est que vous
êtes d'accord mais avec qui sont partis
déjà je suis d'accord je vous ai dit je
suis d'accord avec mon médecin traitant
je suis d'accord avec ma maman qui est
médecin je suis d'accord avec
globalement la politique sanitaire qui a
été ta vie dans ce pays et vous êtes
d'accord
avec vos statistiques mais je trouve que
globalement on s'en est plutôt pas si
mal surtout mais vous êtes d'accord avec
moi est-ce que vous trouvez pas une vie
globalement normale
il me semble quand même que les images
qu'on avait en Chine c'est pas les
images qu'on a vu en France
la Chine et le pays le plus cher mais au
monde il paraît qu'effectivement ça bien
sûr
des images dont je sais pas par qui
elles ont été tournées mais voilà je
veux dire finalement moi je le sais
parce que j'ai vu les images alors ok
d'accord donc peut-être peut-être
comprendre vous m'expliquez que vous
êtes d'accord mais donc je cherche à
comprendre annuel très bien pourquoi pas
très bien mais vous êtes d'accord vous
êtes d'accord aussi moi mais si on est
personne ni nos déprimé
en général c'est 6 mois
alors s'il vous plaît pas en fait vous
êtes d'accord avec tout et avec rien
d'un instant de Guillaume de Béatrice et
non
non parce qu'on les a pas entendu
l'obéissance aveugle c'est ça
c'est comme moi je fais confiance même
quand effectivement on est capable de
dire deux choses complètement
contradictoires bah on fait confiance
quand même sans se rendre compte bah
qu'en fait on est juste en train de se
faire enfumer pourquoi vous parlez qu'on
nous empoisonnés non pas du tout
pourquoi alors qu'est-ce que vous parlez
de ça
Gilles Verdez toi tu es favorable et tu
es contre Fabrice pour que déjà calmos
Ramos j'ai favorable et surtout mettre
des visions quand vous énoncez des faits
vous êtes brillant quand vous devenez
complotiste vous êtes dangereux et là
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de la
Chine et d'image de l'échelle info
détournerait encore
vous accusez les chaînes info de
diffuser de fausses images venant de
Chine qu'est-ce que vous racontez
reprenez laisse-le parler là-haut vous
prenez pas ça ne vous grandit pas oh
qui traite effectivement un journaliste
quand même de complotiste qui a eu
Olivier
de défendre non plus non
tu es personne
je peux le dire la preuve que je peux le
dire c'est que je le redis c'est très
grave ça c'est décision non non
pardonnez-moi quand vous êtes décidés
mais parfois rien dans cette émission je
pense que là il te reste encore 4
secondes pour t'excuser
par ce gouvernement les gens sont morts
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça
vous pouvez le nier tout ce que vous
voulez mais c'est comme ça alors mettre
dans le monde entier à ce moment-là mais
si vous voulez et alors en quoi ça
nous exonère de quoi que ce soit mais
c'est pas on va en parler
je réponds à ce point être complotiste
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
de vous dire que le Pass sanitaire
n'était absolument pas un instrument de
régulation de l'épidémie le Sénat l'a
dit je l'ai dit ça veut dire que les
masques ne protègent pas de l'infection
je l'ai dit une étude co-crain vient de
le dire ça veut dire que les vaccins
effectivement de protéger pas de la
transmission je l'ai dit et ça a été
également dit donc revoyez vos
classiques
on ne sait absolument pas ce qui se
passe en Chine et d'ailleurs vous vous
observez que opportunément on en entend
plus parler de la Chine mais qu'est-ce
qui s'y passe aujourd'hui en Chine
il faut pas tu peux pas dire ça là
Géraldine vous savez tout ce qui se
passe en Chine dites-moi ce qui se passe
si vous savez pas donc si vous savez pas
on est
moi en fait comme ils ne savent pas je
suis d'accord pourquoi faire un vaccin
obligatoire alors que pour le coup on a
aucune réponse oui ça a certainement
sauvé des millions de gens mais là dans
ce cas là ça ne sert à rien
non mais sur Olivier
veyronisation
est-ce que la liberté est-ce que non
c'est pas dans la liberté
je veux rajouter une couche en disant
que les décideurs publics par leur
décision ont conduit à la mort de
centaines et des milliers de gens mais
vous notamment notamment mais vous aussi
peut-être
l'objectif
je le développerai pas non
malheureusement
le confinement par effectivement le Pass
sanitaire dont on sait qu'il n'était pas
une mesure pour lutter contre l'épidémie
le confinement a tué des gens c'est un
fait il en a sauvé combien peu importe
c'est toute la question
c'est pas la question c'est pas la
question puisque vous me reprochez
d'avoir dit que Olivier Véran par ses
décisions quand il nous a senti est à
l'origine de la mort de Jean bah oui je
suis désolé c'est la vérité et c'est
comme ça non mais là non mais comme vous
l'avez formulé tout à l'heure c'est pas
la liberté d'expression c'est de la
déformation absolument vous l'avez
compris
pas de qualifier premièrement
je suis à sa disposition de Paris ça des
conditions je dis j'ai précisé
immédiatement que évidemment qui n'as-tu
personne physiquement voilà pour un
imbécile
bien sûr non mais c'est même le petit
frère
j'ai rien rectifier c'est évident et
décideur public c'est par ses décisions
alors attendez il y a Béatrice qu'est-ce
que vous voulez Béatrice vous êtes
d'accord avec Fabrice sur sur le vaccin
vous non pas de moi je suis défavorable
parce qu'ils nous ont menti surtout à
chaque fois qu'ils ont dit que quelque
chose serait facultatif c'est devenu
obligatoire ils ont fait n'importe quoi
je suis d'accord que avec Fabr et c'est
tout basé sur des études pour le coup
que toutes les mesures qui ont été
prises les mesures liberticides de
confinement de d'excès de masques par
exemple sur les enfants notamment mais
aussi sur les personnes ont été néfastes
et il y a un soignant suspendu qui a
parlé d'un suicide l'autre fois donc
rien que pour ça c'était absolument une
catastrophe et effectivement toutes les
études montrent que tous les pays qui
n'ont pas appliqué ces mesures sans son
sorties aussi bien voire mieux que nous
donc non Géraldine cette politique n'a
pas ne nous a pas sauvé tel Zoro c'est
pas vrai c'est n'importe quoi et ça
c'est le cheval de Troie ils vont
obliger
je pense exactement le contraire de
Béatrice elle est elle est sur sa sur sa
ligne moi je suis sur une voie de bandes
il y a des preuves regardez les chiffres
vous parliez de chiffres et de sciences
regardez la science non mais sauf que
moi je regarde la science c'est ma
science à moi ne me dis pas du tout la
même chose que toi votre science à vous
dans ces cas-là à qui profite le crime
quelle aurait été l'intérêt de ce
gouvernement alors de faire cette
politique c'est vrai qu'on peut utiliser
le monde entier
non non laisse-moi répondre il me pose
une question je pense qu'ils ont tous
été conseillés par les mêmes personnes
tous les pays qui ont fait cette
politique ont été conseillés par
McKinsey c'est un fait c'est de la fête
tu peux dire ce que tu veux c'est en
fait
l'industrie naturelle non mais juste
laisse-moi finir ma femme
des gouvernements sur une politique
sanitaire et dans le même temps pour
client des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
qui
pour raisonnement
et les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
auraient un complot mondial pour
gouvernement pour pour tuer
pour nous Pharma poundou Pharma c'est
effectivement bouscous
à l'origine de la crise majeure des
opioïdes aux États-Unis
pourquoi ils ont donné des œufs
majoritaires
n'importe comment leur intérêt pourquoi
on a découvert ensuite on a découvert
que finalement aujourd'hui
par l'excès d'optéroïde que la guerre du
Vietnam est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer leur intérêt là ce qui s'est
passé c'est que les gens sont devenus
accro à votre médicament
est-ce que vous savez que on a découvert
aux Etats-Unis que les labos enfin que
McKinsey en l'occurrence a proposé aux
boutiques de venir doubler les doses de
venir vendre aux doses maximales le
traitement parce qu'on le savait
pharmacodépendant vous apprenez à
personne que les laboratoires font de
l'argent d'accord
je prends des médicaments et il me sauve
non
c'est que vous laissez entendre non pas
que les les labos gagne de l'argent
jusque ça on le savait mais qui gagne de
l'argent et que finalement cet argent
sert à refinancer certaines campagnes
électorales et c'est tout le but de
cette collection
aux États-Unis il y a effectivement en
moyenne 6 lobbyistes de
l'intervestiotique par sénateur
américain enfin redescend les chanteurs
c'est donc en France mais c'est pareil
donc en français
les de financement de la Sécu sont
rédigés avec le stylo des laboratoire
aujourd'hui a pris toutes ses décisions
parce qu'il voulait l'argent des
laboratoires pharmaceutique pour
financer sa campagne c'est ce que tu dis
tu peux tout mettre
ce qui arrive c'est ce qu'on craignait
depuis des mois on avait peur de se
taper le vaccin à ville on y est ça y
est c'est le Pass Navigo du vaccin on va
recharger les gens bientôt tous les mois
et c'est ce qu'on crée voilà et moi je
veux pas faire le complotiste de base
mais pardon c'est bien que tu viens que
tu reviennes au sujet en tout oui voilà
non mais on on arrête pas de dire que le
covid c'est terminé qu'il y a plus de
masque on enlève les restrictions
sanitaires et comme par hasard on vient
de le dire le seul truc pour lequel il y
a des gens qui s'enrichissent de manière
exponentielle on nous l'impose pourquoi
si on nous dit que le covid c'est
derrière nous laissez-nous tranquille
arrêtez de nous faire chier avec le
vaccin en fait non c'est surtout que moi
j'avais un propos un peu plus nuancé
c'est dur le vaccin si vous avez envie
de parfaites-le en soit on s'en fout
simplement venez pas venez pas
argumenter au nom de la science parce
que tout ça c'est pas de la science et
de la croyance et de la foi c'est du
dogme c'est du commerce et du business
on n'a pas entendu des gens là s'il vous
plaît Delphine moi je voulais je voulais
dire que je suis très contente que
Fabrice est visio soit de retour et on
devrait pas que tout le monde et on
devrait
et on devrait vraiment l'accueillir
comme le messager parce que excusez-moi
dans les faits tous ces métiers
le messager juste donc voilà donc en
fait donc en fait écoutez-le parce que
ben il est un peu visionnaire dans ce
qui va se passer
Gilles Verdez non mais il est
visionnaires de quoi tu es jaloux parce
qu'il a la côte avec les meufs
tu es jaloux parce que toutes les
meubles le pécho arrête un peu comme ça
il est magnifique
c'est juste à chaque fois
tu as raison il parle de croyances à
propos du vaccin non mais c'est du
délire ce qui dit là vous tombez dans le
délire
tu as raison c'est du délire c'est du
délire de dire que je dois me faire
vacciner tous les six mois puis un an
puis trois mois plus 4 mois du coup
c'est quoi la vérité n'est pas une
croyance le vaccin sauf des vies bordel
Fabrice arrêtez un peu j'ai une question
Gilles vous êtes vacciné combien de
doses 3 bah pourquoi pas 4 mais je vais
le faire dès que je peux dès qu'on me le
donne
tellement dans le vaccin mais vous vous
en pressez pas ça moi je vais le faire
très vite
comme tout le monde tu vois le tour de
la table vacciner quatre doses parce que
j'étais pas éligible
c'est 20 doses
non trois doses comment parce que je
crois qu'elle a repris un mec au labo
éligibilité
[Musique]
six mois pour les autres et parce que
les autres merci j'aimerais connaître
j'aimerais qu'on entendement
vraiment vraiment c'est lui qui a raison
sur les trucs des 6 mois pourquoi les
gens vont pas faire la quatrième dose et
moi ce que je veux pas c'est qu'on donne
un pass sanitaire avec ça après tu es
cachée
dans tous les sens ça m'endormir moi je
suis plus con que tous les autres ici
j'ai du mal à me dire
parce que j'ai du mal à me dire que il
va falloir aller faire un vaccin un
rappel d'un vaccin qui n'empêche pas de
contaminer les autres et qui ne me
défend pas voilà moi je suis plus con
que tous les autres pourquoi tu veux
comment tu le sais mais parce que ça son
vide
et là on te dit maintenant on te dit
excuse-moi on peut pas dire ça mais pas
pour aujourd'hui on peut laisser parler
Raymond là qui a pas parlé on te dit
maintenant qu'il y a plus besoin de tu
auras plus d'arrêt de travail si tu as
le covid tu auras plus de trucs tout est
tout est lisse il y a plus de covid
nulle part à qui profite moi je me dis à
qui profite on a l'impression qu'ils ont
absolument besoin de vendre leur
de vaccin aujourd'hui pourquoi il a
raison de se diviser pourquoi
vous courrez pas faire la quatrième dose
vous avez le droit à la prochaine fois
vous y allez pas attendez pas en vous
attendez le Pass sanitaire et qu'on vous
prive des restaurants pour aller vous
piquer allez-y maintenant ou si vous
voulez moi je veux que ce soit libre je
suis intelligent avec ce vacciner
librement voilà alors est-ce que je peux
vous montrer un peu ce que c'est que
l'intelligence pardon alors qui va
parler alors
[Applaudissements]
ça et j'ai toujours été pour le vaccin
et je considère qu'il a sauvé des vies
et qu'il a sauvé le pays en revanche
aujourd'hui je suis contre ce vaccin
obligatoire c'est bien vous dire si je
réfléchis un petit peu que je suis pas
pour pour contrecote systématiquement
quoi non j'ai pas mis le temps c'est
parce que je considère qu'aujourd'hui en
revanche effectivement ça ne tue plus il
y a plus de masque et on connaît les
effets et on sait qui ça touche donc à
partir de là c'est comme la grippe la
grippe c'est mortelle pour certaines
personnes
âgées pour autant la grippe le vaccin
contre obligatoire donc je pense que il
ne faut pas que ce vaccin soit
obligatoire on sait qu'il existe pour
les personnages mais qui sont pas
obligatoire sinon la grippe doit être
obligatoire aussi donc
il a dit le vaccin pour les personnes
fragiles tu as plus tellement envie de
te faire vacciner je me suis rendu
compte maintenant
et on va faire on va rester il va resto
sinon on se repasse les extraits hein
parce que bon tant que tu dormais je
parlais quoi tu as entendu ce que j'ai
dit j'étais pour le vaccin je suis pour
le vaccin aujourd'hui on connaît les
conséquences on connaît exactement ce
que cette maladie qui elle touche quand
comment les masquer tout donc
effectivement aujourd'hui on peut
comparer à la grippe et la grippe tu te
fais vacciner c'est toi qui décide et tu
te fais vacciner si tu considères
qu'elle peut te tuer moi la grippe je ne
suis pas vacciné à mon âge aujourd'hui
et pourtant elle tue des personnages
idem pour le pour le pour le covid c'est
tout c'est du bon sens mais le bon sens
c'est de l'intelligence quand on a pas
de culture il faut du bon sens c'est ce
que j'ai et c'est ce qui te manque et
quand on a la culture et le bon sens et
quand on a la culture et le bon sens
c'est quoi mais c'est pas toi mais c'est
pas toi en tout cas moi parce que je
suis désolé mon cher ami mais depuis
deux ans je dis ce que tu dis ouais ce
que tu sembles découvrir aujourd'hui non
mais tu as regardé les amis bravo il a
fait un moi je dis que en revanche a
sauvé tu dis qu'il a tué il a il a parlé
Fabrice il a regardé les émissions où je
suis intervenu bravo je te félicite
parce que ce que tu viens de dire ça
fait 2 ans que je le dis quand je te dis
j'ai regardé deux trucs toi il est
pélissa euh
il me fait dire un truc que j'ai pas dit
ça m'agace ça m'agace je suis en train
de dire que le vaccin en revanche le
vaccin le vaccin a sauvé ce pays alors
arrête avec ça
on a du sang sur les mains on n'est pas
la même chose
que lui à l'instant le vaccin sauvait
des gens oui maintenant il sauve des
pays c'est extraordinaire quand même et
bientôt il s'ouvre la lune
le problème de votre vaccin cher ami
c'est que ça fait effectivement
maintenant 2 ans que vous lui prêtez des
vertus qu'il n'a pas qu'est-ce que vous
en savez excusez-moi il faut lire autre
chose que Picsou Magazine
[Applaudissements]
ce pays meurt des gens qui pète je l'ai
pas éteint en interrupteur
en fait je suis désolé je l'ai pas
éteint
beaucoup Mathieu merci ça fait deux ans
qu'il est éteint oh la la
[Applaudissements]
vraiment quelle tristesse d'entendre ce
que tu dis et surtout d'essayer de me
mettre de ton côté maintenant et surtout
il a pas de côté il meurt de gens qui
parlent et qui n'y connaissent sur rien
[Rires]
le vaccin a sauvé des gens aujourd'hui
je rejoins Guillaume aujourd'hui on sait
il y a plus de mars et c'est tu sais
quoi si aujourd'hui regarde on est tous
là c'est tout c'est grâce au vaccin
alors merci au vaccin aujourd'hui le
vaccin n'est plus obligatoire fini tu te
prosternes devant le dieu que tu veux
c'est ton affaire oh là là
c'est ta liberté
c'est tout à couper moins bête que ce
que je pensais j'adore
qu'en réalité tout à coup la vaccination
tu la veux bien pour les autres mais
pour toi écoute j'ai un peu de temps
quoi je suis jeune
mais comme la grippe ah ah les autres
moi je ne savais pas tout avant les
autres mais tu te mets toi tu ne sais
toujours rien après les autres
[Applaudissements]
oh là oh ça grand-mère oh la grand-mère
on va voir comment c'était les
spectateurs tiens 11 non arrête 88 %
voilà non à 88%
merci voilà